Merav Yuravlivker: Thank you so much Rachael and let me go ahead and get my screen share, and I saw we have somebody who is,
Merav Yuravlivker: In the woods, I saw that was the first,
Merav Yuravlivker: first comment there so hello to the was, and I also see we have folks from all over the world, so we're really excited to be here with you today,
Merav Yuravlivker: me share my screen here,
Merav Yuravlivker: And this will be interactive so i'm glad to see that there are so many comments already,
Merav Yuravlivker: Okay, so can everyone see my slides,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): we're good perfect wonderful,
Merav Yuravlivker: So today we're going to kick off and talk about the trends that we're seeing in the data space and specifically related to the finance industry before we get started, I always like to set a few,
Merav Yuravlivker: expectations for for these types of virtual webinars what we recommend is to find a quiet place maybe one where there's not too many kids dogs, cats,
Merav Yuravlivker: You know, whatever you have around the House also ask as Rachel mentioned, please stay on mute unless you have a question, or would like to add a comment,
Merav Yuravlivker: Please also silence any alerts from your cell phones and then last but not least, we always encourage participation, we do have some questions throughout this presentation as Rachel mentioned, she will be sharing out the link to slide out,
Merav Yuravlivker: So we'll have about 20 to 30 minutes of of Dmitri and myself, presenting and then we really want to turn it over to you to guide the conversation and make sure that everybody leaves with something actionable today, so if you have questions, please feel free to ask them,
Merav Yuravlivker: Before we dive in just like to set an introduction for myself and my co founder Dmitri,
Merav Yuravlivker: i'm the CEO and co founder of data society, Dmitri is the chief solution architect and co founder as well, we started data society back in 2014 really with one mission, which is to help professionals use data better,
Merav Yuravlivker: We do that with our custom data science training programs that we deliver to large organizations federal agencies fortune 500 companies with specific focus in finance as well,
Merav Yuravlivker: And then we also have a solution side of the House where we build custom software predictive algorithms and also support digital transformation efforts so over the past eight years we've seen a lot,
Merav Yuravlivker: of how data is being implemented in the finance space so we're bringing in a lot of our experience today to share that with you,
Merav Yuravlivker: What you'll walk away with today examples of how data is used in finance trends of data uses in the finance industry, as well as steps that you can take to start integrating data into your operations, because we get that question a lot,
Merav Yuravlivker: And it's really important for us to help other organizations, become more data driven so you'll definitely walk away with some ideas that you'll start to think about how you can use that in your day to day,
Merav Yuravlivker: With that i'm going to turn it over to Dmitri to kick us off,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Thanks rob so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Let me kick off with a case study of how we've leveraged,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): data for financial services use case,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Broadly speaking, what we're seeing is that there's a trend towards using a lot of non traditional data sources in order to make financial decisions, and that is impacting every aspect of finance from underwriting to bond trading,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): In this case, we had the Inter American Development Bank who came to us with the following question,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): They fund a lot of infrastructure projects around the world, primarily in developing countries in Latin America,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And they wanted to mind lending agreements and infrastructure proposals in order to better evaluate the riskiness of those projects and of those funding packages,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): They said, all we have our PDF style documents that describe the terms of those loan agreements,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Can you help us extract data from them in a standard way and then help us build a risk model, such that when,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): New organizations apply for funding grants or loans effectively for infrastructure projects, we have a better framework for determining whether or not they're high risk and therefore what the appropriate monitoring structures and levers need to be,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So we built a bespoke tool for them that did exactly that it connected to a large repository of,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Infrastructure proposals and associated loan documents extracted key terms,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And then looked at the historical outcomes of those projects, in order to build a risk model and say share the key factors and elements inside those loan packages and inside the effectively project plans,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): That help us forecast, what is the likely outcome is a project, going to be over time over budget, what is the likelihood of success, and so on and so forth,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): As a result, we developed an application that they could pull up on their desktops and rerun the workflow to load extract additional information loan information from documents and then price subsequent loans,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): This type of use case of leveraging natural language processing plus machine learning in order to arrive at a risk model,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): is something that we're seeing happen with increased frequency across the financial services space next slide please,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So, broadly speaking, the types of use cases that we're seeing emerging across the board, are generally fall into a handful of buckets risk analytics identifying consumer borrower behaviors and trends,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): The mitigation of operational risks, meaning the actual operational risks of a bank of an insurance company or any other type of specialty lender fraud detection and identity validation and finally payment and transaction processing Those are some of the biggest buckets,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): fraud has been an increasing increasingly growing problem across the world, to the point where there are in fact actual,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Fraud fast factories that had been developed in some countries, like North Korea and Russia that will literally build up the credit histories of a virtual identity start to borrow money,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Through so they will still steal some identity information right you all, probably have heard of the hack of the office of personnel management, the United States right so they'll steal information,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Sometimes they'll buy it on the dark web and they'll start to literally build up a credit history for somebody,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Over the course of years they develop a large borrowing capacity,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And then, when they quote unquote fund the account, they will you know borrow that sort of large target amount that they had and then that is when the fraud actually occurs,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And so that type of corporate is systemic fraud is a growing problem and banks and financial regulators are continuously looking for solutions to combat threats that are not necessarily imminent, but equally are large and systemic,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): In terms of identifying consumer consumer behavior,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): there's a big push towards,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): towards,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Identifying non traditional sources of information about population movement of population behavior so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): What happened was in the pandemic people stopped showing up to places in person right this this virtual virtual presentation is a case in point,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And so, banks sort of to ask themselves that question of do we need physical branches and, if so, how many in where and so we've seen use cases where banks are pulling cell phone data to start to understand the new behaviors and patterns of physical movement,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): juxtaposing that with their general ledger to understand how the local bank locations are being,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): utilized and whether or not there's enough transaction volume to justify actually having a branch open whether it's from a deposit growth standpoint, or a loan growth standpoint,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And so, on the one hand they're investing in digital applications to do that making sure that in cyberspace they're able to avoid fraud,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): While reassessing their on premise their their physical real estate portfolio,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): i'll skip operational risk for now there's a case study i'll touch on a bit later,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): We talked about fraud and finally there's payment and transaction processing so there's a variety of technology products that,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): are increasingly used to transfer value right we've all heard of cryptocurrencies and the latest trend in non fungible tokens which is basically pieces of code that serve as a proof of record that somebody in D created something and somebody else owns it,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): what's interesting about the utilization of technology as a proof as an evidence of something occurring,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Is that if you think about the nature of markets it's all about supply and demand and words it constricted supply and an excess demand you start to have price growth,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): In fact, the largest the best performing asset class over the past 30 years has actually been fine art,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): paintings effectively right so it's a constraint supply you're not going to get any more Impressionist Impressionist paintings and you're looking at prices of work skyrocket from two to 20 million over the past over the past couple of decades,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And so the The ability for technology to serve as a proof of record that something indeed happened,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): is opening up spaces for artists and other creative use cases to actually leverage technology and then finance to actually grow great value that's fascinating trend that's boys to remake a lot of financial the financial space next slide please,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And so what that's fueled is a huge growth and influx of venture capital, so, in fact, last year was a record year in terms of venture capital invested,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Generally, and most of it going, especially into financial technology So you see this semi what is that in quarterly quarterly data, where there was a huge spike in 2021 I kind of continued towards towards the end of the year so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): you're seeing a lot of investors who have identified this this trend and are saying, how can we,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): How can we create entirely new markets,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): That unlock sources of value that were previously closed,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So if you're in the investment Community there's a lot of money being thrown at the sector or whether you're looking to start a company you actually arguably have the best chance of being funded if you're in the financial technology technology space next slide please,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So this huge,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): wealth of opportunity, and this huge influx of money is creating a lot of a lot of opening for skills and demand for skills, so, in fact, the in 2021 the largest applicant technical skill demand is for R and Python programmers in finance,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And that demand right now is hard to fill so you've had immediate price appreciation for Labor of 10 to 20% for people who are in finance and have these types of programming skills,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So the skill requirements kind of go up and down the chain, so if you're thinking about what does it take to actually have a technology application function there's the mechanics of collecting information storing information,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): changing its shape analyzing it and presenting it right and there's a discrete set of technical skills that are necessary to power it,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So skill requirements include knowledge of databases, so in the cloud databases knowledge of data structures,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): and an understanding of how to find patterns and detect statistical statistical significance, so, in fact, when we started data society back in 2014,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): I myself came from the Financial Services side, so I started my career as a as an investment banker, of all things, and then I worked at a quantitative hedge fund for a while and so what we did is built complicated,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): What now you would call machine learning, but basically forecasting models around a variety of financial portfolios, whether it was portfolios of loans or energy portfolios or royalties of,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Pharmaceutical products, and so we refine the quality of our analyses and placed a lot of best using drones analytical methods that at the time we're not standard at a lot of the lot of the funds,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): In the financial services space today there's been abroad recognition that the some of those analyses are no longer appropriate to do in excel right you want to use proper statistical software,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): To do that hands the huge uptick in our Python and there's an explosion of both proprietary and open source tools that are available to you guys so there's a link,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): On this slide for a grant are for better depository,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Of over 160 different packages for the financial services industry i've used a lot of them, you know they're,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): they're really powerful as long as you understand exactly what they're doing and why they're doing it, I highly encourage you to get you guys, to have a look, and what i've learned is because the power is an automation and just higher quality prediction,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): That they can really help you move the needle professionally again whether you're starting a new company and going after some of that venture capital funding or looking to boost your income i'm looking for a job, where,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): manual processes of the past are being increasingly digitized next slide please,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): One of the,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): sort of emblematic displays of how data is changing the financial services space,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Is what the federal deposit insurance corporation so effectively the government was a government organization that is tasked with ensuring the deposits of savings, savings and loans organizations across the United States,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So, if you look if you go to their website that talks about tech sprint's that the champion so it's here on the slide for you,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): you'll read about several textbooks that they've deployed over the past few years and you'll notice that they're all about leveraging technology to address pressing banking problems there are cases where they've,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): asked the Community to identify ways of help the unbanked right so there's roughly 7 million people United States that are towards the bottom of the sort of income income demographic who are unbanked and need additional financial services,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): That they don't have access to so they've asked the Community, how can we reach these people more effectively again think back to identifying,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): validating,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): identity in digital space and then using technology to facilitate payments right which is effectively what those folks need and ability to verify who they are, without a physical access to a bank,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): The ability to share their financial information, make sure that this is not fraudulent and then for banks to actually facilitate payments for these for these individuals,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): There are sprints where they've asked the Community how to in fact validate those identities and finally one we participated, for which we developed,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): A risk framework that is based on something called camels camels is a standard,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Risk measurement framework for banks that the fdic users when they evaluate banks for this soundness,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): The sprint for the fdic task participants to think through how data can be used to alleviate operational risk, so what happens if somebody doesn't show up to work,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): What happens if the bank gets hacked does the funding does do the funds of the clients of the depositors remain intact do loans get evaporated,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And so we designed a framework that leverages operational metrics, such as the bank's data systems, their ability to,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): defend against cyber attack their redundant data redundancy that protects against key personnel deporting so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): we're a framework framework and a technological foundation to do that now to enhance the framework, what we also showed is,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): is how to develop a quantitative model to leverage data that's not traditionally used by regulators by banks themselves to look at their business,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So I know this font is a little small, so we can probably distribute this presentation afterwards, but we actually built a quantitative framework for leveraging things like,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): census data that provides monthly updates on local economic conditions local commodity prices so, for example,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): A lot of small to medium sized banks have well a regional coverage right and for a lot of them, they have heavy exposure to agriculture,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So when there is a precipitous drop in a particular crop localized a certain area, the entire portfolio of the Bank may be at risk, and yet commodity prices are not a traditional metric,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): that are used to evaluate the health of banks, open up by regulators, so we assembled a technological architecture using Google cloud,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And showed how to input data sources from commodity markets from the US census from social media from digital media all in order to create a more encompassing framework that helps evaluate the bank's risk, not just from a financial perspective,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): but also from from an operational one So these are all some of the key things that are changing the mechanic by which the finance industry works increasingly connecting it digitally and creating a much more automated way for managers and regulators to understand the landscape of money,
Next slide please,
Merav Yuravlivker: So we warned you that this would be interactive and we are making good on our promise so based on you know all the information that Dmitri share the fact that we're starting,
Merav Yuravlivker: To be able to combine different types of data sources that finance hasn't really leveraged before one of the questions that we have for you feel free to answer this in the chat,
Merav Yuravlivker: Is the types of data that you're using today because throughout this presentation we're going to transition a little bit more broadly about,
Merav Yuravlivker: how you can start to think about what it means to be a data driven organization and why that's important but before we get started love to hear from you,
Merav Yuravlivker: If you use data, what does that look like or any of you using social media data I see we have someone that's using transaction data card payments mobile wallet payments yep so I could see why that would be popular CRM data,
Merav Yuravlivker: What are some other data sources that you're you're using today,
i'll give another minute,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But can unmute yourself to if you want to even chime in live,
Merav Yuravlivker: Crime data transcripts census CDC,
Merav Yuravlivker: Healthcare yep somebody is actually using sentiment analysis on social networks that's great,
Merav Yuravlivker: Real Estate student data,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So one of the really powerful use case for graph analysis effectively Community detection where,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): If you are able to get transaction data from any kind of network think of, for example, swift the organization that facilitates international payments international bank transfers,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): You actually can understand what are the key notes and therefore key nexus points for a financial system and so understand what are the key risks in a financial system,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): what's interesting is that,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): There was an analysis done by a pro publica back in 2010 if memory serves, and they were doing a retrospective on,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): The financial crisis back in 2007 and 2008 and sort of trying to figure out well how did it come to be this way,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And what they did is collected data from Bloomberg data that was publicly available to everybody, by the way, during the during and leading up to the financial crisis, back in 2008,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And what they did is collected information on something called CEOs are collateralized debt obligations So those are basically pools of loans, a lot of them are mortgage loans, but there are all sorts of pools of loans,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Car you know car loans,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): All sorts of different types of loans and they looked at how different pools of these studios right different studios what they are,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And what was remarkable as they showed a web that showed that all these different studios first of all, were issued by a handful of investment banks like 20,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And a lot of them own pieces of each other so once you do own species of another studio and so on,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And so you could actually see clear as day that there was, in fact, a network of these collateralized debt obligations, such that it took very little for one cdo to default,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Before it's it off a cascade of defaults across the collateralized debt market so such that something like you 1% change in the value of one,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): CEO actually could impact trillions of dollars worth of debt and it had to do a lot more with the structure of these of these securities and how they were priced in her own them rather than anything else, and so, when I saw that,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): sitting back at JP morgan's desk at the time, it became very obvious that had somebody been doing this analysis on open data all along, he could actually identify,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): choke points in the financial system, identify this type of systemic risk much, much earlier, and so I suspect the same types of opportunities are available today so for any of you doing analysis in the financial service financial markets,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): I would encourage you to have a think about how you can use a graph analytic framework in order to identify to understand the financial system better,
Merav Yuravlivker: And, Dmitri before we move on there's somebody who did ask about the research paper article that refers to what you were speaking towards so maybe as i'm presenting if you could see if you could find that and then post that in the chat I think that would be helpful,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Let me see if I can find it well, more i've continued with the presentation,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): we're gonna do I kind of take it away to the next section and then,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): If anybody has questions don't be shy,
Merav Yuravlivker: Absolutely,
Merav Yuravlivker: So thank you so much for for telling us all about that the data that you're using and,
Merav Yuravlivker: Hopefully that's maybe spark some ideas about additional data sources that you can use,
Merav Yuravlivker: You know, one of the big trends that we're seeing in finance and gets Dmitri alluded to earlier, is the fact that more and more institutions are focused on becoming data driven, but a lot of times this term is used,
Merav Yuravlivker: Very in a nebulous way, and so one of the,
Merav Yuravlivker: pieces that we've found to be most helpful is to be able to define a little bit better what does it actually mean to be data driven, how do you know if your data driven and how can you identify the key pieces to work on within the organization,
Merav Yuravlivker: So the way that we've identified that is across two different axes, we have our data literacy, which is the overall knowledge, as well as the,
Merav Yuravlivker: Governance and oversight within an organization and then also the data infrastructure which, especially in finances is crucial to ensure that data is accessible appropriately, and that is also stored securely,
Merav Yuravlivker: So thinking about data infrastructure we've identified these three pillars data collection data storage and data access so in terms of data collection,
Merav Yuravlivker: You know I saw a lot of evidence about the data that folks are using,
Merav Yuravlivker: With its customer transactions CRM data student data so presumably there's some collection that happens on a continuous basis,
Merav Yuravlivker: If not that's definitely something to look into but, even more importantly, making sure that the data is collected in a way that is,
Merav Yuravlivker: Then, easy to analyze and just store is also pretty crucial So if you have a bunch of data that's disorganized maybe there's a lot of missing values that makes it a lot more difficult to pull insights from it,
Merav Yuravlivker: So, ensuring that the data collection, that you have is not only collected in a timely manner, but then also stored well,
Merav Yuravlivker: And then stored in a way that makes it easy to pull insights from the second pillar is data storage I think everyone on this call, especially if you're in the finance industry understand,
Merav Yuravlivker: A lot of the information that you're dealing with is personal information, whether that's credit scores spending histories bank account information and trying that your data is stored securely,
Merav Yuravlivker: Is is paramount to that, but at the same time, the third pillar data access is also very impactful because, if your teams cannot access the data that they need to make timely decisions, then that makes it difficult to use,
Merav Yuravlivker: And that makes it difficult to use the the actual data that you've collected, so you know you can start to ask yourself,
Merav Yuravlivker: The data sources that you're using now is it easy for you to access is it easy for your colleagues to access, if you have these types of questions you know those types of questions are ones, you should be asking yourself in order to make sure that this is,
Merav Yuravlivker: It this is available to you,
Merav Yuravlivker: And then, on the other, axis, we have data literacy and with this,
Merav Yuravlivker: One of the biggest challenges that we see is a communication gap between the data and the non data professionals within an organization,
Merav Yuravlivker: So becoming a more data driven organization really starts from the top and that's in terms of data leadership,
Merav Yuravlivker: Do executives actually champion data utilization I would say most do, but maybe they don't understand the resources,
Merav Yuravlivker: That they need to allocate or the the time they need to give people to better understand how to use data, so if you have a data champion in your organization, if you have one person who is helping set that data strategy,
Merav Yuravlivker: Then that's a good sign that your leadership is taking this very seriously,
Merav Yuravlivker: The second pillar that we have under data literacy is data governance, I think, especially in finance you probably have a lot of guidelines where you can access to data, how you can access the data, who can see the data,
Merav Yuravlivker: Do you have these guidelines somewhere does everybody have access to them are people using data in a way that's uniform to them so,
Merav Yuravlivker: Making sure that across the organization, people are using data in the same way, so that it's easily accessible to all and easily transferable and readable for something simple or something straightforward if you don't have a data dictionary in place, putting one in place already,
Merav Yuravlivker: can help you ensure that all of your variables are defined in the same way, which makes it a lot easier to clean and then to analyze later,
Merav Yuravlivker: last piece is data knowledge does your staff, do you see your colleagues know how to ask the right questions about data do they understand how to interpret the insights about data,
Merav Yuravlivker: Without that it makes it really difficult to start to become more data driven and to use data to inform your insights so you know a lot of ways that we address this,
Merav Yuravlivker: is specifically about developing you know programs within organizations to help them become more data driven and to drive that continuous culture of learning so,
Merav Yuravlivker: As i'm going through this maybe you have some questions,
Merav Yuravlivker: Or maybe you've identified hey what's the key pain point like maybe there's data that you're unable to access or maybe you're seeing that a lot of your colleagues are having difficulty,
Merav Yuravlivker: Asking questions about data, you know one source of data that we see a lot are a bunch of excel spreadsheets that are live on somebody's laptop and then the minute that person leaves,
Merav Yuravlivker: Those those excel spreadsheets disappear right that's something that we refer to as dark data, so this is something that can be ameliorated with data governance or data storage well,
Merav Yuravlivker: Was it something I said,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I don't know,
Merav Yuravlivker: So if you are wondering where's all of this data does all of my data live on excel on my own laptop maybe start thinking about how you can transfer that to a secure,
Merav Yuravlivker: Space that's that's maybe that's on a cloud environment so that others can access it besides you because that type of data, it can be increasingly more important,
Merav Yuravlivker: So talking a little bit about this um,
Merav Yuravlivker: It all starts with us right it all sorts of everybody in the room, so how can you start with data analytics if you're not already doing this already,
Merav Yuravlivker: Make sure you're asking questions about data ask for metrics make your metrics specific make it measurable, so that people understand what you're looking for,
Merav Yuravlivker: And that can help drive the insights that you find and then the decisions that you make behind that,
Merav Yuravlivker: For inventory, you know we asked what type of data, do you have access to i'm curious how many of your colleagues know what type of data, you have,
Merav Yuravlivker: Right so finding the information that you have access to maybe you'll discover that you have,
Merav Yuravlivker: This whole other database you weren't even aware of, maybe you find out that you're already collecting data about something you had questions about in the past,
Merav Yuravlivker: So, especially in a lot of large organizations, we find that most people don't know what's available to them and that's, not just in terms of data that's, also in terms of tools,
Merav Yuravlivker: You know, maybe your organization already has RStudio enterprise right and you weren't aware of that so asking those types of questions can help you better understand that as well,
Merav Yuravlivker: And then you know for collaborating and talk to your colleagues what we've seen,
Merav Yuravlivker: Is when you get a bunch of people in the room to start talking about the challenges that they're facing data or the data they have access to you'll see that a lot of you are working on the same,
Merav Yuravlivker: issues and to be able to work together on that you're you know, instead of doubling the work because you're both solving individually solving it together tends to make that work go faster and you might also see that there are,
Merav Yuravlivker: Other you know aspects and other data sources that you didn't realize you, you had,
Merav Yuravlivker: How can you support data literacy so beyond actions that you're doing yourself what can you do within an organization,
Merav Yuravlivker: Doing these types of lunch and learns internally, perhaps, maybe you'll find this useful,
Merav Yuravlivker: and hopefully you do so, bringing in other experts to speak about these trends, to speak about how data is being used to speak about these different types of use cases to inspire others around you to start to incorporate data,
Merav Yuravlivker: Go to data conferences, setting up training opportunities, based on on skills gap So where do you want to improve your skills in the data spectrum and even planning events such as data competitions, can be a really nice way to,
Merav Yuravlivker: identify top talent and then also encourage others to start to think about how they can apply data to to their work, these are just some ways, maybe concert thinking of,
Merav Yuravlivker: i'm going to pause here for a minute we have two three more slides after this and then we'll we'll stop for conversation so,
Merav Yuravlivker: Based on you know what to make sure talk to you about maybe that helped inspire some questions for you, and then thinking about,
Merav Yuravlivker: How you're using data how your organization is using data I see, we have some questions before i'm going to save those until the end, but i'm curious about the questions that you might have that you want to explore with data analytics maybe you had one before this presentation, maybe,
Merav Yuravlivker: You have one now,
Merav Yuravlivker: So how do I see data catalogs being used in data governance that's a great question um honestly, a lot of it starts with a simple spreadsheet on a shared drive it can be like a Google drive,
Merav Yuravlivker: or a shared document that gives an overview of where data can be accessed and then how people are defining different data terms and different metrics so that's what i've seen most common with,
Merav Yuravlivker: federal agencies right now in the US, there are a lot of agencies that are releasing their own data governance guide that are specific to,
Merav Yuravlivker: The bigger vision and the mission of how they want to be using data in the future so it's a little bit less specific to everyday usage and more specific to the overall vision,
Merav Yuravlivker: Are there any data ontology semantic maps used for knowledge and catalog that's a good question,
Merav Yuravlivker: I mean in terms of semantic backs, you know, there are data dictionaries that are available,
Merav Yuravlivker: Within our that that are semantic dictionary specific to,
Merav Yuravlivker: sentiment analysis so that's what i've seen it being used and,
Merav Yuravlivker: I don't know if Dmitri had any additional insight on that one,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): didn't realize, I was on mute so,
Merav Yuravlivker: you're also your your cameras cover,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Oh sorry about that so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): I don't know of any drove general use case ontology that were that work well pervasively their data models that can help you organize intelligence ontology,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): But at the end of the day, to the best of my knowledge, today, they really tailored to specific use cases, and so there are principles around developing a semantic map or data apology and that's that's a much longer conversation,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): But there isn't sort of a here's how you organize all knowledge type of approach much more of how do you define a threshold for what are the key themes, how are those teams related to some things, what specific what specific items,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): sort of is that related to and so on,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): A good tool that we've used for this type of organization is graph databases so we've used neo for Jay a lot there's a free distribution, that is a paid paid distribution for production great software, so if you're doing something for yourself have a look at new for jace free distribution,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): and have a look at the way that it offers you to catalog data its relationships and metadata that might be nice started cool,
Nice to meet you,
Merav Yuravlivker: Alright, so before we finish up the presentation this is,
Merav Yuravlivker: An area that we always like to emphasize, both in our training programs, and also in our presentations, which is about the the ethical use of data,
Merav Yuravlivker: So this is a case study that maybe some of you know, this was one that was done by target so essentially about 20 years ago at this point in time target had a lot of information they're huge,
Merav Yuravlivker: they're huge retail store in the United States for those who might not live here,
Merav Yuravlivker: And they had a large customer base of of you know, data about purchases past purchases,
Merav Yuravlivker: And wanted to start to predict which of their customers would be pregnant, because they know that when you know, an individual's pregnant,
Merav Yuravlivker: They tend to get more set in their habits and if they can catch somebody during that stage, they tend to be more loyal customers,
Merav Yuravlivker: throughout their life so in order to do that they had their data scientists if you're about to to,
Merav Yuravlivker: To multiple years of data to better understand Okay, which is our customers became pregnant and then, what are the key factors there,
Merav Yuravlivker: That they can use to then predict, who will become pregnant, so they did this analysis and, at the end of this analysis they found some key indicators included on buying ginger ale to help with nausea,
Merav Yuravlivker: stopped buying wine was one of the factors that had a good correlation as well as buying prenatal vitamins and things like that,
Merav Yuravlivker: And, based on their predictions of who would become pregnant they started to send out targeted flyers,
Merav Yuravlivker: And you think this is a great use case of data analytics and it is a demonstration of an effective use case, but what ended up happening is they sent one of these flyers to the parents of a 15 year old, who hadn't told them that she was pregnant,
Merav Yuravlivker: So that became a big case that happened with a few other families as well,
Merav Yuravlivker: And it started to bring up the question of it's one thing to be able to mine customer data for insights but how can you make sure you're using it in a way that doesn't cause harm doesn't you know have ethical implications to it,
Merav Yuravlivker: So it's important, especially given that we're in the finance space to think about how we're using customer data and how we need to be mindful of that fact,
Merav Yuravlivker: Now, interestingly enough what target ended up doing it's not that they don't use that data for insights anymore, what happens is that they start to put lawn mowers next to baby cribs so they just are a little bit more subtle about how they advertise that in the future,
Merav Yuravlivker: Speaking about ethical considerations another one that's popped up, especially in the past few years is about biases that exist in our current data that inform our models so again,
Merav Yuravlivker: it's our responsibility to ask these types of questions um there's one where it's you know how does the data reflect the society that we're in today, and if it does perpetuate any stereotypes or biases, how can we build models for future prediction or, for example,
Merav Yuravlivker: granting loans that will mitigate some of those biases and rest, so that we don't perpetuate that, and this is a,
Merav Yuravlivker: difficult question i'm spending a few minutes on it, whereas there's there's a much larger conversation to be had, but the important point to get across here is,
Merav Yuravlivker: As you are building these models as you're involved in these models, make sure to ask these questions about you know, accounting for biases,
Merav Yuravlivker: Before the data is being put into the model, making sure that the model accounts for that and understanding how to mitigate that so that you can make the best decisions for your customers without introducing you know some biases that might already exist in the data,
Merav Yuravlivker: Last last piece that i'll talk about is you know we talked a little bit about data infrastructure, Dmitri talked,
Merav Yuravlivker: About a few case studies that he's seen, but on the other side there's that data literacy component of that and,
Merav Yuravlivker: This is an example of how a lot of financial institutions today are starting to realize it's not only the infrastructure, they need to have in place but it's also the appropriate stuff with those skills,
Merav Yuravlivker: So we've done a lot of work in in the finance space with that,
Merav Yuravlivker: One of the use cases specifically is with discover financial services where they actually developed a pretty robust infrastructure and what they realized is they had a lot of new hires coming in,
Merav Yuravlivker: That maybe had some of the prerequisite skills, with a good foundation, but not all of the skills that they wanted to,
Merav Yuravlivker: You know that that they needed in order to be effective, so we work with them to build an onboarding program that helped train them,
Merav Yuravlivker: In our as well as in other tools, including sequel and snowflake so that by the time that they left,
Merav Yuravlivker: That onboarding process, they felt much more comfortable within the infrastructure that they had so they can be much more effective off the BAT,
Merav Yuravlivker: We see a lot of this happening and it's not just the onboarding process but because hiring is so difficult right now for data scientists,
Merav Yuravlivker: they're rare breed and i'd say, especially in the finance industry, it can be really difficult a lot of financial institutions are now turning to this training aspect, whether they're doing it internally or they're bringing somebody else in to help develop that skill set across the organization,
Merav Yuravlivker: So i'll finish up with this question here, I know that there's some other questions in the chat in the chat that are more specific, so I can pause here and just say first of all thank you for for coming to this talk today Rachel, thank you for organizing it,
Merav Yuravlivker: We love RStudio, especially the hangouts and we find that you know this just the Community has been really supportive and lovely so we want to make sure this is valuable for you um and now is your time to ask us questions i'm going to pause here i'm going to stop sharing my screen,
Merav Yuravlivker: So thank you some of you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So much rob and Dmitri that was great I see a lot of questions coming into the zoom chat and then we also have the slideshow link, if you want to ask questions anonymously there as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I did also just I meant to do this in the beginning and rob your presentation reminded me this when you talked about maybe planning lunch and learns with other people across your team,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): The RStudio finance team is is listening in on as well, and they would be happy to help with us too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And if you ever want to see maybe who else from your company is using RStudio to and they're a great resource for that if you want to just say hello Kevin maybe,
Kevin Hayden: Everybody yeah This is my first time joining great great to see a lot of you a fantastic job on the presentation that was really interesting,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Thank you, thank you, I see some questions in the chat I was going to dive into those at that that's a good time,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): that's perfect yep,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So I think Rachel The first question was from you in terms of what kinds of organizations,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Provide employees with technical skill development versus expect you to figure it out on your own so it's tough to paint paint with a broad brush,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): We work with a number of financial services organizations that invest heavily in new employee onboarding and continuous employee development, you know we work a lot with,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): discover into American Development Bank capital one all those organizations and they'll have robust new employee and existing employee training programs, I know, we had very robust one back at JPMorgan so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): it's tough for me to say, well, this type of organization likes to do this versus you know not that,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So stuff to put them in buckets but I know a lot of organizations do have great programs and based on our experience, those who do not have similar hat there who do not have something like that in place,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): are increasingly looking to deploy those types of programs we're seeing a lot of interest,
Merav Yuravlivker: And i'll just add on to what major was saying, where I think almost every organization that we speak to or work with has some sort of online training component,
Merav Yuravlivker: And that can be really helpful, I think, especially for a lot of folks on this call, who maybe already have a foundation and our Python and maybe just need to scale up in one or two things,
Merav Yuravlivker: But we found that a lot of people who are new to the space tend to get really overwhelmed with the amount of information that there is they're not quite sure where to start and that's where organizations are starting to bring in something that's a little bit more,
Merav Yuravlivker: tailored and a little bit more structured to help both increase accountability also develop that community of sharing and collaboration and so doing that kind of in tandem with one another, helps build that robust learning culture,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome I can help read out some of the questions, too, and if,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): anyone wants to jump in and ask their question live surveying I see you asked a great question the chat if you want to jump in,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see you're unmuted but I can't hear you yet,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I can start i'll i'll jump to your jeans and then Oh, now we can hear you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay yeah,
Sarang Rao: So thank you guys, I was a brilliant presentations a presentation thanks for that is my second question was around one of the challenges that you know we face is,
Sarang Rao: figuring out how best to have access into standardized schema documents like xp rl and then pulling that into our for some sort of standardized financial modeling and analysis like you have any tips or experience that you could share,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): yeah so in our experience it's been less about the domain and more about the approach right so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): X brl is a very useful tool, you know to publish financial records data,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): But when we are then taking those financial records data and trying to come up with an analysis it's much more about,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): For example, a data structure that Linda self the text analysis right so as I mentioned before Jay has its own structure for Meta tagging and relating data in non in non stars giveaways,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): If you're looking at graph analysis it's a different approach if you're looking at you know classification algorithms they all have their own sort of data formats,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): That you would need so, unfortunately I we I haven't encountered anything specific that sort of is universal for financial modeling,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Because it's more specific to are you looking for portfolio analysis you're trying to you know figure out the sharpe ratio for your portfolio, or are you looking for,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): churn metrics or something else, so it tends to be more analysis style specific,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): If anybody has seen something i'd love to i'd love to hear from you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): and feel free to put that into the chat to have, if you want to weigh in there, and you eugene I see you had a question as well in the chat and would you like to jump in and add some more context on that one,
Eugene: Sure, a near for Jay i've used here and there, but my curiosity is more is there some sort of rule of thumb when scaling up Neil for Jay because we all know, sort of graph network,
Eugene: Type tools have a scalability problem you know, the more vertices the more edges everything explodes sort of exponentially, so I was just curious if there's a,
Eugene: rule of thumb around number of cpus amount of Ram as your as your network scales for for sort of making do for J run in a minimum malleable way not on a cluster,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): yeah so, unfortunately, not the right person to ask, I need to have our director of engineering on on the line for this question, but I know we've he figured this problem out last year, so I can connect you guys afterwards, if you drop me an email,
Eugene: Thanks,
Merav Yuravlivker: And just letting everyone know,
Merav Yuravlivker: That I did put in,
Merav Yuravlivker: Both my my email and demetrius email in case, your question as an answer you want to learn more or I think if you things question, you need a more specific answer and we're happy to connect you with the right person and continue that conversation as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Some thinking around and Greg or I see asked a question around R and Python to if you want to jump in,
Gregoire Mansio: Yes, thank you very much for the presentation we Robin demetrius was very interesting and it would have liked to know, because I know Python is also,
Gregoire Mansio: More and more us in the finance industry, and I would have liked to have your impression and feelings about how are in beta on evolves or are adopting and also the second question I asked,
Gregoire Mansio: What do you think are the two or three other main languages that are entering the finance data driven analysis, please,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): yeah absolutely so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): you're right in that the sort of Python user community has grown somewhat faster because it's grown on the backs of software engineers,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Rather than than, for example, I started as an art user and so that's still my my first love, as far as programming languages go,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And I find that, for example, our syntax is tends to be simpler than that of Python So if you have a software engineering background,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Picking up Python can you pretty trivial because you're already familiar with the notion of data structures,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): If you are starting from an excel or a bba background, then Python might look somewhat foreign and our is going to be a lot easier for you to adopt,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Most people who are in finance actually started in some form of spreadsheets upper right,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So to them transitioning into our would actually be easier,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And in my experience are is going to give you just easier faster options for prototyping proving your point doing the analysis, creating interactive visualization standing up and like application with something like are shiny so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): i'm a huge fan of our and that's the main language which I programming I don't think that the fact that,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): there's been such a huge uptake in Python, for example, precludes another language like are from being you know just as widely used and helpful ultimately i've learned it's about your personal preference and what gets the job done faster,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Those two I think still dominate you know, there are going to be some languages that come into play when you're talking about scale systems,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): But I would attribute them less to finance like there's nothing about finance and the structure of a different language that make them better adapted to to finance right,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): But when you're talking about some scaled applications, especially for transaction processing scala is obviously important right,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): But that's has to do more, due to its sort of software engineering and data piping capabilities, rather than because it's better suited to finance in some way, shape or form to my experience,
Gregoire Mansio: Okay,
Sarang Rao: If I should,
Sarang Rao: ask you a bit more on that are worse is Python that even even for us, we get that,
Sarang Rao: get into that situation or question quite often,
Sarang Rao: Based on your experience,
Sarang Rao: How do you find like convincing or working with teams, where business side are they excel well worse and they might find are a lot more palatable,
Sarang Rao: But the technology groups, then come in and say Okay, no, we are not very comfortable with people using our and they were like,
Sarang Rao: On the software side there's a much bigger preference for Python it's like working with clients, or even within the organization and going through this maze of what should be,
Sarang Rao: encouraged or discouraged, or can you even have both of them working and what kind of relationship should there be between R and Python,
Sarang Rao: or between business and technology people, how do you navigate conversations, like those sure,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So I would push on the word comfortable and who is comfortable with what and who is in the sort of in the right lane in terms of being comfortable with what right software engineering is going to be responsible for security scale,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): code, but the finance team is responsible for the analysis being correct right, and so, in my experience is really the way that I see it, is if you're,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): writing a piece of code you better be confident that it's working correctly from just a mathematical standpoint,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And if the finance team is using aren't as comfortable and our than that has to be the code that actually runs the financial analysis now,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): There are lots of you know, ways to call a Python right and our routine from Python and Python routine from our so they are interchangeable and lots of hooks around it, so it shouldn't be you know we everybody must use one language or other language, there are,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Lots of ways to make the two compatible in fact we do that regularly in our line of work right there's a lot of packages that are just better and are there in Python and, frankly, my first and you should limit yourself to one of the other,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So then, you know the conversation is look if you're writing most of the workflow and Python why can't you call this our sub routine because our analysis works in there,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): If the engineering team wants to reconfigure the tl to in Python well that's their prerogative you right there thinking about the compute time,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): But there shouldn't be sort of a debate about you know, do you need to change the actual mathematical analysis from one language to another that doesn't feel like a good use of time, given the interoperability that's available,
Sarang Rao: sounds good thanks absolutely,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I know we're getting down to the end of our time here, but I don't know if you have a few minutes to run over Robin Dmitri is that,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Okay, absolutely,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome i'm just scrolling through the questions I see davin you'd ask the question, if you want to jump in and and I felt live,
Davin Cermak: Yes, i'll be fine,
Davin Cermak: yeah i'm just really curious you talked a lot about the financial sector, having trouble finding,
Davin Cermak: qualified staff to bring on full time and what do you see for trends in,
Davin Cermak: That type of analysis being available for freelance workers or outside organizations consultants things like that I could just kind of comment on that I appreciate it,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Sure, I don't have any stats to speak about the trend on freelancing specifically but generally I try to think about things from first principles and,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): When a person or a tool doesn't does not make sense right so i'll answer this question kind of the same way that answered the R vs Python question, there are great use cases for when to use somebody who is a freelancer,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): You know you're usually paying them on a per project or an hourly basis and usually they would be more expensive than a w two employee right,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And you can usually get them on board, for that very narrow kind of use case much faster than a w two,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And so there is a reason to utilize a freelancer, for example, or an outsourced firm when you need to get something accomplished really quickly but it's an in and out kind of task,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): If you're talking about somebody who is a permanent higher,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Well there's a legal question about do you want them to be 10 in iowa w two right there's actually it's actually more of a legal and HR question that substance question and then, finally, if you have a capability that's ultimately going to be core,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): You probably want that to live with your full stamp timestamp of kind of bet their careers on working with you for the long run, so you know my experience, whether you whether you outsourcing or freelancing it's great to get initiative going,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): To make sure that the capabilities online quickly, but then equally have a plan to kind of have some some full time staff,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Having said that, I don't have a command of the trend of freelance us but I bet if you went to someone like upward they might have some some data analysis around that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you to meet you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And scrolling through to see some of the questions we missed and and Emilio I see you had asked one in the chat to do you want to jump in if you're still on,
Emilio: yeah so, can you hear me yep,
Emilio: Thank you are he was wanting to know if you have any preference without him he he application usually for their applications integrate risk I know it's a very john keel still working on progress, but I appreciate there is any our library, can he can start learning or any other,
Emilio: might be useful, thank you,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Just to make sure that I understand your data i'm using you talking about sort of sustainability metrics for relatively yesterday,
Emilio: yeah it's a little more specifically the cingulate nurse,
Emilio: big push to implement climate impacts into loan portfolio right now,
Emilio: But it's limited to mortgage,
Emilio: I want to know there's any other kind of type of loans that are might be already been modeling or any and for rhonda,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): yeah so,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): I could talk on this topic for hours i'll try to try to keep it short,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): There is a really big push across both regulators investors and industry participants around how to measure climate exposure climate risk,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): That is true for both energy producing assets so infrastructure is a big area where this applies and equally loans to companies that had meaningful climate exposure, not just insurance companies but businesses based in coastal areas,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): The the I know the SEC, is doing a lot of work around the appropriate amount of financial disclosures that would be required from regulatory perspective with respect to as G or climate change risk,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): We wrote a big white paper form about that topic so there's no standard framework that i'm aware of, right now, they are all,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): there's a lot of research and they're all generally sector dependent, so you mentioned mortgage certainly right again for coastal areas energy generation assets that's very much true for them,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): But i'm not aware of a framework that sort of says here's exactly how to think about it pervasively,
Emilio: You think,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, Dmitri i'm just checking through to see if there any other questions that I missed so feel free to jump in if there's one that you asked earlier and we didn't see,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): You see, a comment from Brian about the fact that most finance output ends up in excel and PowerPoint so using our markdown simplifies that task I couldn't agree with you more we use very heavy,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): we're very heavy users of our markdown in a lot of stuff that we do from trading to the actual or solutions custom solution part of the projects that we build,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): So I couldn't agree with you more i'm a huge fan of our for financial services applications,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And I think that there needs to be a sort of intellectual acknowledgement that there is software development and there are good tools for software development,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And there are tools for finance where you need to get to a analytical result result quickly and be able to communicate that easily with other decision makers,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And I find that are as much better for that second use case, so my from my standpoint it's not about what's better our Python right they're both great tools,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): But they have very distinct use cases and they have very underused libraries for calling the sub routines from each other and creating interoperability, I think it's much more about that than what is better,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Well, thank you so much for having Dmitri for an awesome presentation and i'll give people a few more seconds, if you want to jump in and raise your hand with other questions,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But that was great and awesome to get the Community together, I did ask in the chat i'm not sure if anyone's on from the arm finance conference team, but I saw that they had a call for papers out for the conference happening later this year they shared in the chat as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But thank you all so much for joining today and Merav & Dmitri i'll work on getting the recording together, and if you have the slides you could send over to me that would be awesome too, and I could put that with the recording yep well,
Merav Yuravlivker: we'll get that to you and thank you so much for putting together such an awesome group super interactive lots of questions, which is exactly what we love, hopefully, everyone feels like they're taking away some new information today,
Merav Yuravlivker: that's really our goal is to just empower people to use data better and However, we can help do that, where we're happy to,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): yeah echo that Thank you everybody morrow Thank you very much for the kind words in the chat really appreciate all of you for for dialing in and all the really good questions and the great discussion,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): Thank you very much,
Dmitri Adler (Data Society): And, of course, thank you to the our team, you know to Rachel and Kevin for organizing this and welcoming us and make it and putting this whole production together obviously this wouldn't happen without them, so thank you guys so much,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you have a great rest of the day, everyone,